foreign
today by Deputy attorney general Lisa
Monaco and FBI director Paul abate today
the justice department arrested Jack
Douglas deshara in connection with an
investigation into alleged unauthorized
removal retention and transmission of
classified National Defense information
is an employee of the United States Air
Force National Guard
FBI agents took to Shira into custody
earlier this afternoon without incident
he will have an initial appearance at
the U.S District Court for the District
of Massachusetts
I want to thank the FBI justice
department prosecutors and our
colleagues at the Department of Defense
for their diligent work on this case
this investigation is ongoing we will
share more information at the
appropriate time thanks everyone
lawful access to these documents sir